[Music]
hey you guys it's matinee episode 55
doing a shudder and Netflix and a
theater this week so we got all the
[ __ ] bases covered don't we yeah
they're pretty good they're pretty good
movies this week yeah like I said kind
of an enjoyable week that we had yeah
now as I said the first we're gonna talk
about we're um you know we're trying to
review like all of the new episodes of
the creep show series that is airing on
shudder yeah so this week we're going to
be talking about episode three yeah
shudder shudder and creep show they
delivered they deliver this week yeah
this is it these are these have all been
really good it's like like I said you
know you're gonna get when there's two
stories on each one and eight like I
said that that's really cool that they
try to do like a diversity of different
types of stories so they usually put two
they're not very similar like on the
same episode which i think is a cool
idea um this one I feel like the first
half of it the first story was maybe I
liked it but I think it was like the
weakest one of the series so far but
then the second one that they did was
like kick-ass and I really really liked
it so the first one was called All
Hallows Eve and it was directed by John
Harrison who did a couple of the other
segments also he was the assistant
director on the original Creepshow movie
from 1982 and he was also the director
of tales from the dark side the movie
and this was actually written by Bruce
Jones who's probably best known as a
comic book writer um he wrote for Marvel
and it would stuff he did an Incredible
Hulk from you know in the early 2000s
also and I didn't know this until I
looked up his IMDB page he also wrote
the short story called the Jennifer that
the that Dario Argento directed for the
first season of Masters of Horror so I
thought that was kind of cool that was
actually a really good segment so he was
the writer on this and it kind of it's
cool because it's it has kind of like a
really cool like Halloween type setting
I've seen some reviewers compared to
like Ray Bradbury or like something
wicked this way comes there's no like
that it does have a little bit of that
vibe to it and it's just about these
five kids that are going around
trick-or-treating and you know they go
to these people's houses and they're
kind of dicks and people are clearly
afraid of them so you know that there
kind of like some sketchy [ __ ] going on
kind of reminded me of that old Twilight
episode about the kid that could wish
people way into the corn it did remind
me a bit of that as well yeah but yeah
there's teenagers yeah be able to do
whatever they want and I've also seen it
compared to you know Twilight Zone the
movie where they did that episode I
think Scatman Crothers was in it called
kick-the-can where it was kind of like
it's it's not like horror outright it's
like it has a scary premise and it's
like I'm I hate to spoil it but it's not
really spoiling anything because you'll
know like within the first two minutes
that these kids are dead and that
they're going around exacting revenge on
you know some don't something that
happened a long time ago and they
apparently come back after every
Halloween like his vengeful spirits or
whatever until their revenge is exacted
you know so in that way like I really
liked it the kids were fine and you know
I liked the whole Halloweeny atmosphere
of it cuz I you know I love when stuff
is set and Halloween and like the color
palette was really nice and stuff but I
maybe because I knew where the story was
going like very early so it seemed like
it was really slow even though it was
only 15 minutes long you know I'm saying
yeah but you know I liked it that was
all right yeah I did too and like I said
it's you know that's it's not really a
big criticism because I mean it's still
good they're very simple stories like
you said there were 15 minutes long so
you know there's not a lot of complicate
not a lot of complication in them and I
was about like what an old Twilight Zone
was when we - yeah marshals out of them
yeah because you know Twilight Zone was
only half hour long most of it was damn
commercials yeah that's so really it was
like one Twilight Zone episode I think
they're 18 minutes yeah one Twilight
Zone episode was really nothing more
than damn half a creek show yeah pretty
much
and there were not they weren't super
complicated
those hold yeah you don't have a lot of
time to get into like a really complex
type of story and the thing you have to
thank to that creep show I mean
obviously the ideas from it came from
the old AC comics and those were very
straightforward mostly revenge stories
or you know some evil person getting
their comeuppance type of stories and
you know so there wasn't like a lot of
you know not a lot of character
development now it was basically
one concept and they just like ran with
that and ran with it to its conclusion
they might try to do anything we gotta
get a story in there and then do a twist
and then you know I mean there's there's
not there's just not a lot of time there
yeah that's so I looked at it that way
he's okay yeah and like I said I did
like this when I liked the whole
atmosphere of it it seemed a little long
like I said and you could see where it
was going but it's that really wasn't
anything it wasn't it it was actually
more sad than like a horror you know
what I mean it wasn't gory or anything
really um but you know the ending of it
was kind of sad so it was more like a
poignant kind of story but um you know I
said I still liked it otherwise I just
think it's the weakest segment of the of
all the ones that we've seen so far
now the second one I love the [ __ ] out
of this one this was called the man in
the suitcase this was directed by David
Bruckner who also directed the movie the
ritual which is awesome you should go
watch it also he did one called the
signal which I haven't seen but I've
heard is really good and he did the
Amateur Night segment in the first VHS
movie you know so that was good too
now this one um was actually written by
somebody who's like a novelist and a
poet I don't think they've written
anything for TV or anything nothing that
I could find anyways names Christopher
Ulman now this is actually I because I
love the batshit premise of this so it
deals with this like stoner guy named
Justin and he's coming back from I think
he was visiting his parents or something
and his girlfriend is just broken up
with him and he's having like a shitty
day or whatever he's at the airport he
thinks they've lost his luggage and then
all of a sudden this suitcase like pops
out after everyone's left and everything
he's like that looks like his suitcase
so he takes it home now he gets back to
his flat grass apartment and he hears
somebody like talking from inside of the
suitcase yeah
at first he thinks it's his roommate
it's not he opens the suitcase and there
is a man like all contorted yeah up in
the sit on this way arms going this when
his face sticking up and it's this
Indian guy you know and talking to him
it's weird it's pretty damn weird and he
doesn't seem to try to even get him out
of the damn suitcase he does at first
couldn't pull him out
what ends up happening because the guy
is just like oh please help me and stuff
like that so the guy the kid tries to
pull him out but it's really really
painful cuz he's all twisted up like a
pretzel and that is when he finds out
that every time the man in the suitcase
experiences pain he spits out coins a
gold coin like a an expensive one
because he goes and gets it appraised
after one of them gets spit out and it's
like 250 $300 the guy gives him for it
and he could probably get more for it
for that it's like a Krugerrand or
something like that so perhaps unwisely
justin tells his slacker roommate and
his [ __ ] ass ex-girlfriend about this
couple they come over and they think
because they've been [ __ ] around
behind his back but like they think that
he's murdered a dude because they come
in the apartment they just see a hand
sticking out of the suitcase but then he
has to tell them no it's this guy and oh
by the way every time he feels pain he
spits a gold coin out and you can see
where this is gonna go it's like well I
just like love I love when they do like
these batshit premises like it like this
and what I mean the story unfolds and it
just it makes sense when you start
getting to the end what the hell is
going on but I don't know if you want to
spoil it but I would just know I did I
wouldn't spoil it I have to say that
there's a really really good like kind
of a practical I don't wanna call it a
monster effect necessarily it's not
really a monster but a practical effect
that reminded me very much of Twilight's
and the movie the segment that was
actually based on that kid in the
cornfield one except they changed it up
a little bit called the it's a good life
or whatever yeah but in Twilight Zone
the movie they did it was like the kid
named Anthony and they had all this
really cool like practical like wacky
like the big ol rabbit with like the
teeth and everything like that they had
all this like really cool practical
effects and this has one like that yeah
that reminded me of that and it was
super super cool looking yeah but I just
like really loved the premise the guy in
the suitcase is hilarious um just like
the way he's just kind of like he's kind
of resigned to it you know what I mean
cuz it's like they're trying to like
kick the [ __ ] out of him so they can get
more money out of him and he's just like
you know yeah that's that goes a lot so
it's like it made it really funny yeah
it's so far the series is
heavy and practical effects it looks
good well yeah like I said cuz a lot of
its kind of you know this is kind of
Greg Nicotero thing and he has his holes
can't be studios everything so you've
seen the episode that comes out after
this it's even better yeah it's like
yeah will be really but yeah serious
it's a strong series and getting better
yeah so far it's like this one like I
said it had probably like what I thought
was the weakest episode but it also had
what I think is probably the strongest
episode so far I have to say I think I
might like the man in the suitcase a
little bit more than house at the head
cuz up until now house of the head was
my favorite so this one might have just
edged it out just because see I like the
ones that have this weird premises like
house of the head that's only there's
like a little zombie head inside her
doll house and it's like killing all her
dolls and civilly I mean that's awesome
that's a great concept on the one next
week that we're gonna do next week down
was pretty cool with the companion yeah
yeah yeah based on Joel and that's very
good yeah but like I said you know I
like that they have this kind of variety
of stuff and I like that all the stories
aren't the same and like I said they've
kind of you know they've dug pretty deep
got some good directors and good writers
and stuff like that so yeah this was a
another good episode this week so like I
said if you're not I'm shudder you
better go check
you
please if you hear if you hear ripping
sounds of the background that's baby
cookie has decided that she found this
folded up piece of paper and she's just
gonna tear that tear the [ __ ] out of it
just because that's her job man that's
what she does she take a [ __ ] alright so
the next thing we're gonna be talking
about is a Netflix thriller that just
just got on their like October 11th or
something like that kind of like a lot
of buzz on social media about this one
it's actually kind of a sort of a horror
movie more of a thriller it is called
fractured yeah now this was directed by
Brad Anderson who has done many movies
but he also did the kick-ass session
nine one of the best horror movies and
he also did The Machinist the one where
Christian Bale looked like a skeleton
because he just ate gum for six months
this one was pretty good I actually
really enjoyed this movie um it seems
like I feel like opinions are divided
I've seen like a lot of people that said
they really really loved it and like
some people were like oh I saw
everything coming but I didn't see well
I sort of did but it's like I didn't see
exactly like how it was gonna end up so
what the premise of this movie is and I
should know - it was written by Alan
McElroy who also wrote Halloween for
return of Michael Myers and the wrong
turn movies which the only the first of
which I've seen in action was actually
pretty good Sam Worthington is in this
and Robert you were telling me it's like
who is that guy he's in like he's in so
much stuff he was an avatar that's
probably where you and it's funny
because well it's probably not funny for
him but it's like when he was an avatar
which was like the biggest movie of that
year he's probably like I'm gonna be a
star and then like not that not really I
mean he's still in stuff but it's like
he's in like a lot of kind of you know
not any like big a-list kind of stuff
and I saw I kind of feel bad for him but
oh this that's the weird thing about
avatar it's like it was like the biggest
movie of that year and it's like no one
really talks about it anymore right
Kyle like twister remember how big
twister was like back in the 90s yeah
yeah and then like but aha a year or two
later it's like everybody just forgot
tornado tornado yeah
so just weird how that happens
everyone's gets obsessed with it and
then no one remembers it a few years
later yeah Lily rabe is also in this who
most people probably know from American
Horror Story so the premise of this and
I was actually intrigued when I just
like saw the thing on Netflix my god
that sounds pretty good it sounds like
right up my alley so it's this guy and
his wife and their little daughter whose
name is periwinkle although they call
her peri and they're driving from there
I guess it's the grandparents house they
had had Thanksgiving there or something
and apparently it didn't go too well so
I guess the dad like played by Sam
Worthington was like he's a recovering
alcoholic and bloody blah and so they're
having like a fight on the way home in
the car now Perry has to I think they're
driving back to Minneapolis or something
I think they mentioned now Perry has to
pay or something like that so they
stopped at like a gas station at which
point there is a an accident not a car
accident but another kind of like you
know slip and fall type of accident or
something like that
Perry ostensibly breaks her arm and they
have to go to a hospital that's kind of
like out in the middle of nowhere to get
the little girl treated for her broken
arm and possibly a head injury they
think she might have a head injury also
so he takes them in so he takes the wife
and daughter into the hospital and he
tries when there's like all that
bureaucratic [ __ ] it was like we
don't take your insurance and once your
blood type and everyone is like shifty
as [ __ ] you know what I mean and it's
like super super crowded and so they're
waiting around and like finally finally
like a doctor comes to seeing them and
he seems really nice and everything's
like okay well we're gonna take your
daughter down to get a cat scan or
something like that just to make sure
she doesn't head injury blah blah so the
wife and the daughter go down to get a
cat scan or so they say then sam
worthington falls asleep in the waiting
room any wakes up several hours later
and they say that they have no record of
the way for the daughter ever having
been in the hospital yeah they don't
remember her there and she's not there
and there's no file for her there's
nothing like that he starts freaking out
as you would yeah
then they starts telling him well you
had a head injury in this accident you
know the cops are there and everything
they're saying like you're nuts yeah you
know and that's where the games begin
this was I was like I said I'm not I
don't want to spoil it
because this just came out like a war
two ago and it's one of those ones where
you know you don't know you're seeing
things from like an unreliable narrator
I guess it's one of those type of
thrillers where it's like you don't know
if he's great but then like there's some
kind of sketchy [ __ ] going on and you're
like well maybe okay baby that shake it
should just go like it could go either
way you're not sure for a while and I
think it's really good the way they kind
of like walk to that tightrope because
like the whole time I was watching I was
like wait wait is he nuts was he you
know well mate wait no because they're
acting really weird too but yeah but
maybe that's just from his perspective
what the [ __ ] is going on so it's like
it was really good it was like really
really tense and like really really
frustrating because you know you could
feel like that dudes frustration just
like growing and growing and growing
because they're telling you look you
came in by yourself you had a head
injury and it's like now you're behaving
like a crazy person and he's like you
know he you know he thinks of like [ __ ]
that you would think of he's like oh you
know you have security cameras let's see
the footage and it's like Oh
conveniently you know the wife and water
that would have been sitting under the
thing and it's like you know other
that's what I mean so there's like all
this like stuff that you know you're not
sure like what exactly is going on yeah
so you know I'm not gonna spoil the end
or anything like that you might be able
to see it coming I don't know like I
said I sort of saw it coming but not
entirely um but it really does kind of
like keep you invested in it and it's
got like a really cool I really liked
the score it was like this just really
weird kind of bad no he was pretty good
wasn't my kind of movie I watch it again
but I do appreciate it it was good as
thrillers go it was actually a pretty
good one um I've seen this compared a
lot to flight plan which had a similar
kind of premise except on an airplane
you know where somebody's like oh well
you never had a kid or whatever I don't
know it was like a long time ago I
thought I've also seen it compared to
shutter island' so it is kind of similar
to that so if you dug those then you
will probably dig this as well because
it's in a similar kind of vibe so you
know it's like I said it's gotten kind
of mixed reviews I've seen like a couple
horror critics that like really really
loved it and then some were just like oh
it's a kind of bland you know so I
couldn't really you know focus on or
anything but I thought it was really
good I thought
like all acting was really good it
really kept you like invested in the
characters and what was going on and I
really liked the the kind of creepiness
of the hospital and like how all the
doctors and nurses seemed kind of shady
and like you weren't really sure what
they're up to and like all this other
kind of [ __ ] but you know I thought it
was really good so if you like thrillers
you should probably check it out because
I thought it was a pretty damn awesome
in for the third movie this week we
actually went to the theater to see
Zombieland double tap yeah this is the
best one of the week really I enjoyed
this one very much yeah
now you had not seen you have not seen
the first zombie land current no they
did do a double feature but a list
wouldn't pay for it so we didn't go and
you don't have to see the first one do
it to appreciate know umm yeah some of
the stuff will did relate to the first
one I'm you can tell you know if you
just jump into part 2 you can tell some
of the stuff was referring to what
happened in part 1 yeah isn't I don't
really think it makes it even more funny
to know that maybe only the Bill Murray
angle yeah what a help but no if you
haven't seen part 1 you know feel free
to go ahead and see part 2 it's pretty
good it's it's about kind of like Shaun
of the Dead that same tone it's a comedy
zombie movie
it does have zombie stuff in it but it's
mostly comedy if you ask me yeah so you
know if you're expecting something like
walking dead then well I don't think
anybody that saw zombie land would
expect walking right because this was
very much like the first one and
honestly I have to say that I am very
impressed because after the first zombie
land came out and they didn't really
expect it to be all that big a hit of a
hit but it kind of became a cult classic
so they were talking about making a
sequel like only a year or two after the
first zombie land came out like in 2009
all the you know cast members said they
would come back and we're really excited
about it stuff because they really like
these characters but for some reason it
went into development hell it just never
happened and [ __ ] like that so it's
amazing that you know ten years later
think about with a sequel to it and they
got like all of the original cast back
Woody Harrelson his back Estella Hasse
they got [ __ ] Emma Stone back as
Wichita and like she's like you know she
was kind of you know she was a known
actress then but it's like that was ten
years ago now she's been nominated for
three [ __ ] Oscars she's like in all
this you know what I mean so it's like
everyone's like a bigger way bigger star
like he meant Jesse Eisenberg and stuff
he's been nominated for an Oscar since
then Woody Harrelson still looks good
for such an old guy he really does
he doesn't really look that much
different than he did in the first up
yeah but yeah so if you like the first
one I don't see any reason why you
wouldn't like this one um it's very you
know it's it's kind of like um a loose
kind of thing it's more about the comedy
it's more about the road trip it's more
about the characters interactions with
each other other than any kind of like
solid there is a plot you know the whole
plot is it's pretty much been you know I
think it's still it's ten years and the
world of the movie just like it's been
10 years in our world you know the four
main characters which it's all a little
rock Columbus and Tallahassee have all
kind of you know if they have this
little ersatz family going they have
moved into the White House and you know
or farting around on that now and
there's also kind of a thing where I
guess Columbus you know in Wichita been
together a long time he proposes
marriage she freaks out there's also a
thing about Little Rock because in the
first movie I think she was only 11 or
12 you know she brought a kid so now
she's a grown up person and she wants to
go out and find you know a man and go
find start a family of her own and
Tallahassee is being kind of like overly
protective I guess he's like her father
figure so they kind of take off and then
there's this there's this whole subplot
about super zombies about how zombies
are getting some of them are getting
smarter somewhere we're getting harder
to kill like you can't just DoubleTap
them anymore and so since they're all
like afraid of what might happen to
Little Rock because she hooks up with
this hippie like this quintessential
like stereotypical hippie guy named
Berkeley and so they kind of set out to
find her like toward Graceland and stuff
so it's kind of like like I said you
don't really have to have seen the first
one although there were like a lot of
kind of references back to the first one
so I think you would've like appreciate
it more because you be like oh yeah just
like you know what I mean but you don't
have to have seen that and if you like
the first one I really don't see any
reason why you wouldn't like this one
it's very it's very charming it's very
funny it's it's these same characters
and they just the four of them just work
really well together and I think it's
cool that they got all of them back I
also should say that there's like this
one new character that well
a couple new characters too but the one
new character they introduce Madison
yeah yeah it's a [ __ ] trip yeah it's
like well because this character the
cool thing about her character is that
she's supposed to be like annoying and
vapid and stuff like that and that could
go tragically wrong like she could be
for real annoying but she pulls it off
really well like even though yeah she's
annoying character but she's also kind
of like she's got also kind of like cute
adorable you know what I mean so which I
think that's like a really hard thing to
pull off but she did a really good job
of doing that but she was like a funny
funny typical airhead yeah yeah she was
just like totally and like and like how
she survived the apocalypse like where
she's been living and stuff like that
was just like funny as hell yeah and
also I should say too that yeah this is
the same directors the first one
everything like that so yeah it's just
kind of like just a fun road trip II
kind of movie with occasional zombies I
kind of liked the end you know that kind
of the end big end set piece you know
where there go that all the super
zombies come and they have to fight them
and stuff like that so but it's nobody
watches this for like an action movie or
like a horror movie it's just like a
comedy that happens to have some bees in
it like you said it's kind of like Shaun
of the Dead that kind of vibe or like
the first zombie land why why a lot of
people liked it you said that you liked
it but you liked the dead don't die
better yeah
it's kind of like that was more like a
zombie movie that's yeah that's just it
was just kind of a good good comedy set
in a zombie setting yeah apocalyptic
setting because I mean you have a thing
to wear I mean when the first zombie
land came out in 2009 I mean The Walking
Dead hadn't even started the comic book
had the you know the graphic novel was
going but the TV show hadn't started so
that was kind of pre like zombies
everywhere so it was like a little bit
of a fresh air so the fact that they
could come out in 2019 when there's just
like zombie saturation in every [ __ ]
media and still make a movie that's
entertaining to watch and still funny
but I think it was wise that they didn't
evoke this so much on the zombies they
do it's like you know when they're on
the
and like when they have to make a stop
somewhere and then they'll get attacked
by zombies and have to shoot them and
stuff like that but it's not really the
main focus of the story and I'm glad
that they made it like that because even
the first one was kind of it's just its
own thing yeah are just like more about
the characters and stuff like that so
like I said if you really like the first
one then you will probably love this one
as well I I haven't seen the first one
in a long time um but and I remember the
first one being really funny I think
this one might be slightly funnier but I
would have to see the first one again
like to confirm that I'm not really sure
I remember you know I laughed a lot
during this one that was like a lot of
really good it was entertaining yeah
there was a lot of good set piece in it
but yeah it's just a good time it's not
it's not deep it's not anything like
that it's just like a fun you know just
like a fun character study that's pretty
much it with like [ __ ] zombies in it
can't beat that
so yeah I'll be laying a double tap go
check it out
you